sort of said from the beginning of
sunset overdrive what would happen if
societal norms are stripped away would
we become creative like Burning Man or
would we become something oppressive
like Lord of the Flies for Marcus and I
were first working on our hit for sunset
overdrive one of the things we focus on
a lot was these different fashion trends
and just people dressing in odd ways we
had a huge huge collection of all these
different ideas of like mods and rockers
and there's all kinds of crazy different
fashion eras and we hand this to Justin
and thank goodness she paired them down
to to something reasonable and doable we
started taking all the fashion records
they gave us and separating them out
into three different buckets mainstream
fashions basically anything that a
normal person would wear street fashion
is something that comes out of street
culture such as email and goth costumes
are something that someone from a
particular culture group might wear or
it's something you might even wear for
Halloween all the sunset vanity takes
from one or more of these buckets which
makes them both relatable and
understandable diversity was very
important to me because it is all about
Flair choice and being who you want to
be and I think it definitely makes our
game stand apart from other games I
think one of the interesting things
about sunset overdrive is that most of
our concept artists are actually not
from the United States I think this will
appeal to a lot of different people
my team takes concepts from Vasili our
concept artist over in Russia we wanted
to embrace a bunch of different
archetypes that you'd see in pop culture
and mash them together to create our own
look and since that Overdrive we allow
you to choose from many different
archetypes in the game that includes
different races different body types big
and small and different genders we have
outfits that are meant to be together
and you can get them as presets in the
game you can combine all the different
pieces to make exactly what you want so
if you get your Day of the Dead face
paint you can combine that with your
wrestling pants your chainmail shirt and
your cowboy boots every item that you
unlock in the game will have havok
physic's applied to it as well so when
you're running around the world they
really want you to feel like it's alive
clothes sort of provide people's most
obvious identity and can even act as
masks it was really important to me and
Marcus that vanity stay as as just a
purely vanity element that we didn't
attach our PG stats or any other bonuses
to it and there was something that was a
really big fight around the studio
Marcus and I just had to stand firm and
say you know it's really important to
this game that players be able to wear
whatever they want to wear to express
themselves
I like the hairstyles especially the
creepy 80s metal band style I just like
the way it looks moving around when
you're doing our traversal in Sunset
City I would say that my favorite of all
time is that we can be a luchador given
the right combination I mean any chance
to actually be a luchador running around
sunset city is pretty amazing one of my
favorite vanity items this is is the
bunny ears it's so absurd and beard just
feels good running around with with tall
bunny ears I don't I don't know why I
don't wear them all the time for items I
can't really believe we got in we do
have a physics-based kangaroo head strap
to your crotch and nothing else
oh the kangaroo got beats early on when
we were pitching the game drew hit used
in a reference that he would be wearing
nothing but a kangaroo copies we knew we
wanted it to be really different and
really stylized pretty out-there
and it just seems so absurd but we
started pitching it that way and every
pitch we did we would talk about the
kangaroo codpiece and I think it was one
of the first things you can can look at
or talk about and be like now that is
sunset overdrive
so after you've dressed up your
character and you've got them looking
the way you want we still got a ton of
customization with the weapons the traps
two amps a lot of different things on
the gameplay side
so thanks for coming to Comic Con and
checking sunset overdrive out hope you
pick it up on October 28th and let your
freak flag fly hi
Xbox one now starting at 399